can I ask you a question on that yeah uh
just a side tangent how do you prevent
when you're imagining yourself to be a p
tendril how do you prevent from going
crazy I mean this is kind of the
Nietzsche question of like uh you have
to be very careful thinking outside the
Norms of society
because you might fall off like mentally
you're so connected as a human to the
the collective intelligence yeah that in
order to question intuitions you have to
step aside step outside of it for a
brief moment how do you prevent yourself
from going crazy I think I used to think
think
that was a concern
um and then you learned so much about
the brain no and I've and I've had and
I've had experiences of deep depression
and I struggled with anxiety my whole
life
I think in order to be a good scientist
and in order to be a truthfully you know
let's say um
to allow yourself to be curious and
honest in your curiosity I think it's
inevitable that lots of ideas and
theories and hypotheses will just sound
crazy and that is always how we've
Advanced science and maybe you know nine
out of ten ideas are crazy and you crazy
meaning they're actually not correct
um
but all of I mean it's as I said all of
the big scientific breakthroughs all of
the truths we've uncovered that are the
um
earth-shattering truths that we uncover
they really do sound crazy at first so I
don't think one necessarily leads to a
type of mental illness I see mental
illness in a very different category and
I think some people
are more susceptible to being
destabilized by this type of thinking
and that might be a legitimate concern
for some people that kind of being
grounded in everyday life
is important for my psychological health
the more time I spend thinking about the
bigger picture and
outside of everyday life the more
happy I I am the more expansive I feel
um I mean it feels it feels nourishing
to me it feels like it makes me more
sane not less well that's a happiness
but in terms of your ability to see the
truth that you can be happy and uh guess
I don't see mental illness necessarily
being linked to Truth Or Not truth so we
were talking about minimizing mental
illness yeah but also truth is a
different dimension so you have to you
can go crazy in both directions you can
uh like you know you could be extremely
happy and they are uh flat earthers you
can believe the Earth is flat right
because there actually I mean I'm sure
there's good books on this but it's
somehow really comforting it's fun and
comforting to believe you've figured out
the thing that everybody else hasn't
figured out I think that's what
conspiracy theories always provide
people